So last year,
a fascinating study came out in the
journal Science,
um,
from a team led by Betsy Sparrow at
Columbia.
And in the study those scientists showed
that people who used Google and who
thought that they would be able to
access information on a computer later
on didn't remember it as well as the
people who didn't think they would have
access to it.
So you have one kind of key variable.
Do you think you'll be able to use your
computer later on to find this
information?
The answer is no.
You're going to remember it.
If the answer is yes,
you're not going to remember it,
but you will remember where to find it.
So you'll remember where it was stored.
You'll remember what the folder was,
you remember how to access it on the
computer.
So it's not that you're not remembering
anything,
it's at,
you're remembering a very different
thing.
Do you use your memory to store the
actual piece of information?
Do you use it to store the retrieval
process?
So I take a few things from this.
Um,
thing.
One technology can be very bad for our
memory if we let it be bad for it.
So if we always rely on it,
and if we have this attitude of,
oh,
I don't need to remember this because
I'll always be able to look it up,
you won't remember it,
and then you won't have that knowledge
in your head and then you won't have
anything in your attic to play with.
You won't have that knowledge base.
You won't be able to be imaginative like
homes.
You won't be able to reach those
conclusions because your attic will be
pretty bare.
But we can also use it to enhance our
memory,
um,
by saying,
okay,
I know that there are these great
technological benefits,
why don't I use that to create this
virtual storage space for myself?
So homes does this,
two homes has files that he accesses and
he says,
Watson,
you know,
look up my file for this case.
Look up my file for this case.
So he remembers that he has the file.
He remembers that there was a case.
He doesn't necessarily remember all of
these details.
So you can think of Google as this
vastly expanded Holmesii and filing
system.
So you can use it for exactly that.
What are the things that I want to
remember and that I want to be able to
access later on and focus on remembering
how to access them and then keep your
mind space for those things that you
think will be important for you to know
at any point.
So the exercise that I like to say for
myself as if I were on a desert island
with no power or I don't even have to go
to a desert island in Hurricane Sandy,
I had no power,
no Internet,
no cell phone service,
nothing.
So if hurricane sandy strikes again and
I don't have anything,
do I have everything that I need
immediately in my head?
Um,
what are those things that I really
can't rely on a computer for?
Yeah.